as is when we first met used to give me
so much anxiety he wouldn't never cash
his checks
oh forget about them that's me so when I
would find like a check for $10,000
that's two years old and it would I
would have I went through this whole
process of having them reissued so I
sent his accountant just a pile of
checks that I'd found in the last two
years yeah and it I could not believe
that this guy had just been stashing
random that is really for someone who
goes to Arlington improv to make a
couple more thousand but the actual the
literal principle on the money you could
have deposited you missed out on all
that that's an accounting joke
crowd-surfing let me defend myself okay
let me diplomat I do that too by the way
Natasha's always complaining she finds
like [ __ ] wads of cash kilos of coke
but she does you know what the ultimate
gangster move at The Comedy Store is
never pick up your never cuz I'll do
that I'll be like going through my
checks and I don't do very often okay
but at the end of the day I am a Jew no
matter how successful I've become and
I'll be thumbing through it and then
you'll get to like one guy and it's just
like oh [ __ ] you you just don't need
this well I'm under else right so I
would go to that at the at the office of
the Comedy Store is that ears are like a
what do you call it a a box or yeah
filing a filing box right and it's up
meeting alphabetized and under l but I'd
have to dig through all of Martin
Lawrence's and it's like 3,000 Martin
Lawrence IX cuz he doesn't [ __ ] give
a [ __ ] yeah I pick it up what I'll tell
you why I pick it up I pick it up
because because I have had financial
problems in the last 10 years with my
arrests and stuff so I want everyone to
know that I don't behave like that
anymore
okay are you looking at in the camp yeah
I care about I mean there were times
where I haven't made any money I didn't
know there was a camera at first I
thought maybe you're disaffected
which he does right so I'm letting
everyone know that I'm you not like that
anymore
and also I I call it shadow money it's
like total I go buy shoes and stuff like
that with that right so it's like a
selling merch on the road right I always
think like this isn't real money with
the merch I'll just go this this funds
my trip like what and do whatever I want
and they else with the store just to let
you guys know we get $15 right a set so
it's not like it's thousands of dollars
but after six months here of kind of
there's a nice fly right and they so
that's what I do I wait six months I'll
go and I'll go buy some you know made
worn t-shirts or something you know but
Martin Lawrence literally has three to
four thousand checks and they're
probably worth by now in the tens of
thousands really funny he doesn't need
it he's gonna hear this podcast oh yeah
hey guys sorry to interrupt but we have
this awesome sponsor to tell you about
guess what Smith